all right this is one of those nights
you've got to stay tuned for the hour
there is so much new information to
cover it gets complicated but it does
all fit together and I promise guess
what you won't get this anywhere else on
TV we start with new explosive
information in the developing scandal
involving former top FBI official his
name is Peter struck and according to
reports from over the weekend struck was
removed from Muller's investigation this
summer after it was discovered that he
was sending anti-trump text messages to
his girlfriend a woman named Lisa Paige
she worked as a top FBI lawyer under
deputy director Andrew McCabe now since
then Fox News has learned that the
Office of Inspector General is now
reviewing Peter Struck's role in the
Clinton email server investigation and
from what we know struck who is an
anti-trump Hillary Clinton loving FBI
official was intimately involved in
investigating Hillary Clinton's use of a
private email server no just stop for a
second now think about James Comey he
was writing an exoneration before an
investigation and our own catherine
herridge is reporting that struck was on
the ground floor of that Clinton email
server investigation this is crucial now
that includes participating in the July
2nd 2016 interview of the former
Secretary of State also remember she was
not under oath and struck was involved
in recommending whether or not Hillary
Clinton should be prosecuted
remember they hadn't fully investigated
and Fox News has confirmed that the FBI
official actually was the one that
changed the language in James commis
draft letter before the investigation
was concluded about Hillary Clinton the
legal term grossly negligent he changed
it to extremely careless and the FBI
agent also helped draft James Comey his
now infamous exoneration statement that
let Clinton off the hook they never did
the investigation and struck led the
probe into classified Huma Abedin emails
this guy's everywhere that were found on
Anthony Weiner's computer now house
investigators are also telling Fox News
tonight they believe that it was struck
that is tied to the FBI's handling of
the antique
fake news phony Russian dossier and the
FISA surveillance of a trump campaign
associate now what this all means is
that the fix was in on the Clinton
investigation what we have now is just
more evidence incontrovertible evidence
and speaking of the fake news dossier
Catherine Herridge is also reporting
tonight that FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe is the key witness that Congress
now wants to interview about that
dossier
but McCabe he's not going to show up to
testify on Thursday he is thought to
have been the FBI's key point person or
the handler of former British m6 agent
Christopher Steele the guy that created
the phony dossier and paid Russians to
lie to influence you in that election
now remember according to reports a
political action committee tied to the
Virginia Governor Terry McAuliffe best
friends with the Clintons remember he
gave a half a million dollars to Andrew
McCabe's wife Jill she was running for
her Virginia State Senate seat now
Virginia's Democratic Party also gave
Jill McCabe over two hundred thousand
dollars an obscene amount to any state
Senate candidate now president Trump is
reacting to this new information he's
tweeting out after years of Comey with
the phony and dishonest Clinton
investigation and more running the FBI
it's reputation is in tatters worse than
history
but fear not we will bring it back to
greatness the president's a hundred
percent right about James Comey and
about Hillary Clinton and about there
being a double standard for lieutenant
journal General Michael Flynn the
president commented further on all of
this let's take a look well I feel badly
for general Flynn I feel very badly he's
led a very strong life and I feel very
badly John I will say this Hillary
Clinton lied many times to the FBI
nothing happened to her Flynn lied and
they destroyed his life I think it's a
shame Hillary Clinton on the fourth of
July weekend went to the FBI not under
oath it was the most incredible thing
anyone's ever seen
she lied many times nothing happened to
her Flynn lied and it's like they ruined
his life it's very unfair now I know
this is a ton of information to unpack
here so let me break this down even
further for you here's what all of this
means we have an anti-trump Pro Hillary
Clinton top FBI official that is
directly involved in letting Hillary
Clinton walk free
before interviewing the key people in
the investigation including Hillary
Clinton they exonerated Clinton before
ever concluding the investigation then
the same FBI official helped oversee
Special Counsel Robert Muller's probe
into possible election interference and
according to Sara Carter's reporting
interviewed Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn
this guy's abusively biased we have been
saying for months that this is a
political witch-hunt this new
information about Peter struck is a
smoking gun these types of tactics
they're only used in banana republics
now House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez he is now
threatening to hold the FBI and the DOJ
in contempt of Congress for stonewalling
about why this guy struck was fired back
in August and what all of you need to
know the American people tonight you
need to know this how deeply was this
one guy Peter struck involved in
Muller's investigation because other
than Michael Flynn who else did he
interview why didn't he put Hillary
under oath and where else could struck
of influenced and compromised this
investigation with what we now know was
a politically biased agenda remember
lieutenant general Flynn he was
surveilled he was unmask his name was
leaked to the press that is illegal that
is a crime nobody's been investigated or
arrested so what they did to Flynn is
illegal and we can also we can't
discount the other massive conflicts of
interest the other red flags coming from
special counsel Muller's team for
example key members of Muller's team
look at the money on your screen donated
tens of thousands of dollars not to any
Republicans Democrats like Barack Obama
and Hillary Clinton how can anybody
honestly say that those
people are going to be fair and
impartial after supporting liberal
politicians with huge amounts of money
including president Trump's 2016
opponent this stinks to high heaven and
as the investigator Andrew Weissman
another questionable member and choice
by Muller's team our friend and
colleague Greg Jarrett did some digging
into Weissman's past here's what he
found back during the Enron accounting
scandal Weitzman was a hard-charging
prosecutor on the task force that
brought a controversial obstruction of
justice case against the accounting firm
Arthur Andersen that eventually put that
company out of business
it caused tens of thousands of people
their jobs and it was for nothing
because in 2005 the Supreme Court of the
United States overturned the obstruction
of justice conviction in a unanimous 9-0
ruling next to impossible and it's not
the only example of Weissman's
aggressive tactics resulting in a case
being overturned the convictions of a
business transaction between Enron and
Merrill Lynch it sent people to jail was
also reversed by the Fifth Circuit Court
of Appeals critics have also accused
Weissman of intimidating witnesses
creating crimes that do not even exist
and in one case in particular
withholding exculpatory evidence that
would have helped to defend it and just
like Muller Weissman is also tied to the
corrupt uranium one deal and the ensuing
cover-up
now Weissman ran the do Jay's fraud
section during the Russian bribery
scheme and Gregg Jarrett actually
noticed it was his name and his
signature on the bottom of the plea
agreement signed by the Russian
businessman involved in that case and we
can't forget that Muller is also what
that's friends BFF with James Comey a
huge massive conflict of interest and
potentially even a violation of law all
of this is inexcusable in any country
that cares about the rule of law you
should not be allowed to tolerate this
in any way shape manner or form and we
should be asking ourselves a simple
question why in god's name would robert
muller put this abusively biased team
together of unethical political
satyrs who have an agenda that we can
now prove why are they involved in this
investigation it's been one giant
pattern of bias and abuse of power and
we have a tremendous amount of respect
on this program for those of you that
watch for law enforcement we have a
tremendous respect for the intelligence
community who put their lives on the
line for us every day but because of
politics what our Justice Department has
people in it like Peter struck that are
abusively politically biased what is the
result we now have a two-tiered justice
system that I've been warning about it
is now creating a clear and present
danger to this Republic if we weaponize
the tools of surveillance the powerful
tools and if we have two sets of
standards for justice and people in
power think they know what's in the best
interest of you the American people and
will undermine a duly elected president
and try and get him thrown out of office
since the day he's elected we will have
then lost this country and tonight
there's another major angle to the story
that we cannot ignore or discount as the
washington examiners byron york points
out in a new article the investigation
into michael Flynn was not about Russia
collusion or conspiracy between the
Trump campaign and Russia Russia Russia
rather it hinges on what's known as the
Logan Act let me explain what this is
according New York law the Logan Act is
a 218 year old law in this country a law
that prohibits private citizens from
acting on behalf of the United States
and disputes with foreign governments
guess what in two hundred eighteen years
nobody has ever been prosecuted under
this law and many legal experts call it
archaic and simply irrelevant and some
even go as far to say that it's
unconstitutional but this is what played
that law played the central role in the
Obama administration's investigation
into Flynn never mind the surveillance
unmasking and illegal leaks of
intelligence it's reportedly why the FBI
agents went to the White House to
interview Flynn back in January 24th
about discussions that he had during the
transition period with his counterpart
the Russian ambassador about sanctions
deal
mama administration have placed on
Russia and a UN resolution on Israel big
deal that would have been his job this
is the interview where Flynn quote lied
to the FBI which led to his guilty plea
again nothing to do with Russia but
let's take a step back for a minute now
during this transition period Obama's
State Department said they didn't have
any problem with the Trump transition
team reaching out to foreign officials
they said it watch this this building
doesn't see anything necessarily you
know inappropriate about contact between
members of the incoming administration
and foreign officials no matter what
country they're from now right no and
again this has been ongoing I mean we
stand ready if they want to work through
the State Department to contact some of
these individuals but we have no you
know no comment or no problem with them
doing such on their own for all of this
to be based on whether general Flynn Oh
35 years servant of his country that he
violated a two hundred and eighteen year
old law which no one has ever been
prosecuted under is stunning and that's
not all former federal prosecutor Andy
McCarthy is also saying this is now an
obstruction of justice investigation and
the ultimate goal is to impeach
president Trump where did you hear that
before and finally tonight as we often
say on the show we are not the destroyed
Trump media and if you're watching at
home have no doubts about fake news not
being a clear present danger to the
Trump administration they are the
willing accomplices in all of this and
we have an example that should make you
a believer it's scary it's real and it
proves what we've been saying on this
program since oh wait
journalism in America is dead and on
Friday morning as news was breaking
about general Flynn pleading guilty for
lying to the FBI
ABC News chief investigative
correspondent Brian Ross reported that
Flynn was prepared to testify that it
was candidate Trump that directed him to
make contact with the Russians here's a
report it certainly would seem to
suggest that Michael Flynn had a fair
of information to offer the special
counsel in return that's right George he
has promised a full cooperation to the
mower team he's prepared to testify we
are told by a confident against
President Trump against members of from
family and others in the White House he
is prepared to testify that President
Trump as a candidate Donald Trump
ordered him directed him to make contact
with the Russians which contradicts all
that Trump has said at this point
hours later Ross had to quote change his
tune and quote corrected his reporting
and here's what he said on nightly news
David the clarification tonight on
something one of Flynn's confidants told
us and we reported earlier today he said
the president had asked Flynn to contact
Russia during the campaign
he's now clarifying that saying
according to Flynn candidate Trump asked
him during the campaign to find ways to
repair relations with Russia and other
hotspots and then after the election the
president-elect asked him to told him to
contact Russia on issues including
working together to fight Isis hello big
difference between candidate Trump and
president elect Trump asking Flynn to
contact his soon-to-be counterparts and
according to the Washington Post on
Twitter Brian Ross initially issued a
tweet promoting his fake news report
about quote well candidate Trump which
was retweeted 25,000 times before it was
ultimately deleted now this erroneous
reporting or let's call it what it is
lie was being spread over and over again
by numerous news outlets all day on
Friday before Brian Ross had to walk
back the story and on Saturday ABC News
announced its suspending Ross for four
weeks without pay by the way a little
too little little too late and
unfortunately for ABC this isn't the
first time Brian Ross has been accused
of peddling fake news I have all history
of it like for example in 2012 when Ross
Ross falsely suggested the Colorado mass
shooter James Holmes he could be tied to
the tea party that turned out to be
wrong too